[Musik]
ich habe nur gute oder schlechte
nachricht für euch gute nachricht ist es
mein auge eigentlich so gut wie gehalt
ist also dass keine riesige spannung
mehr hier ist ein pickel die schlechte
nacht ist allerdings ich habe fieber und
bin krank und halsschmerzen mit
kopfschmerzen und ich bin fett und
hässlich du schaut irgendwie auch nichts
gebracht gleich weniger herzlich wenn
ich meinen bart abrasieren
ich sehe immer noch gleich aus in der
zeit wo ich allerdings versucht habe
meine herzlichkeit irgendwie ein
bisschen zu verstecken was allerdings
wirklich leider erfolglos blieb sind
noch zwei weitere personen hier
angekommen zu uns ins haus an die nord
sehen also nicht mehr nur julia und ich
sind jetzt hier sondern ich stelle euch
mal vor tara meine schwester marx nicht
meine schwester gs an strand und ich
habe so einen titel geschrieben dass wir
heute unsere instagram die ems mal
vorlesen und durchgehend aber es ist
krankheits und wir gehen jetzt erst mal
schwimmen gehen an strahlend ich will
kurzfristig von den blumen machen studie
fordern besondere computer setzt sie
einmal auf ich wollte die leben
wir sind am strand angekommen
[Musik]
leute es ist tatsächlich nicht so
sinnvoll eine kamera mit in den mund zu
nehmen und dann einfach ich bin richtig
fett in der muschel eingetreten und ein
ganzer fuß stirbt gerade mal werde ich
versuchen gewesen ich habe zwar nicht
bestätigt worden
aber ich bin krank und das war
vielleicht nicht so gut jedoch gehen
jetzt erst mal ein fischbrötchen essen
du freust dich wieder richtig gut und
ich war gar kein kaufen wir haben
dreimal als sie gekauft und 11 wie heißt
das als das geben da riegel als also
jetzt kommen extreme max und sarah sind
gerade zurück hier angekommen und was
sie sagt den einkaufswagen abgezogen das
sind sarah und julia hier aber meine
damen und herren starten direkt im
display eingeblendet am islam die ems
lesen von weise nicht jule luca und
sarah hier
wir haben jeder so 7 die ems glaube ich
mal rausgesucht vor den letzten tagen
wie ein bisschen lustig war ein
verstörendes aufteilt deswegen will ich
sagen sparen mit meinen sieben die ems
und zwar die erste ist diese hier
hey sexy was machst du zwinker smiley
ein wild und binde ramon übrigens ganz
denn die mädels und schreiben aber nicht
mich ein youtube knotet ist echt nice
macht weiter so finde dich cool und dann
berichtigt contents noch das noch falsch
geschrieben megawatt achtzehnter juli
2016 hallo luca und dann zwei jahre
später okay bei lucca
naja ich bisschen gelebt nächste der
sonne mehr warum halb fünf in der nacht
einen punkt geschickt ja danke danke
schön dafür kann sein dass du willst
wenn ja willkommen im club stets nach
kot wollte ich dir nur mal sagen also
gegen dich zwischen bitte das wäre
besser für uns alle auch sein
danke dafür letzte die npd hier
vorbereitet habe ist das hier
da beide person einfach jeden im audi
geschickt ihre skills wesens würde ich
sagen machen wir weiter achter dass man
findet diese was sich da unten ich störe
nächsten die ems sind jetzt von juda
deswegen hier die erste kanzler vorlesen
hey wie gehts dir bisher fließt aber
schon studiums aber am kurs scheiße auf
jeden fall zustimmen
ich bin eine gute kombination der
schweizer flug kann ich wirklich viel
härter balla ok alles klar
mit einbringen
mache ich auf diese weise die behörde
dann ist dein album ja ich glaube du
bist auf der suche nach einem
also ich finds tief und kommt aus weimar
ist die ems und jetzt von sarah wenn man
sein alter kann ich dann hatte ich meine
story die den klassiker auf bekommen
haben dann ein paar jetzt auch einen
klassen enthält dann soll der korken
verein daraus flutschen
warum das einfach nur nett gemeinter
tipp wie sie betonte flutschen
nutzungsvertrag über sarah richtig
geschrieben und noch mal korrigiert
richtig geschrieben sage ja hab dann
verloren könntest du mir nicht noch mal
geben ok zugrunde sorry habe die einen
schönen sonntag was ist das für eine
kutsche anmache dass jemand was ihr
angetan hat wieso dir dein name bei
juden city geteilt das ist realist ich
weiß auch nicht dass juden oder server
allgemein flächen habe ich schon lange
nicht mehr gesehen ich muss ehrlich
sagen das hat mir sogar ein bisschen tag
für sind natürlich sarah gesucht so die
eine frau sie so richtig lieb sender
sehen ist sarah dann zu viel macht nicht
der neu gedichtet bevorzugst ebenso die
mischung einer außergewöhnlichen art und
einer unkonventionellen weise zur haben
möchte von allen guten geistern fixiert
dann bist du deine unterricht nicht so
nicht in unterwäsche gesehen hat das ist
genug heimische dass wir was mitnehmen
nein sie optimale bild an
ja leute wir wollten einfach mal so ein
happy end frau suchen dann haben wir es
jetzt jeder siebenfach getan
ja wir gehen jetzt los essen leute wir
haben gut gegessen aber ich ging noch
frauen bleibt das vergessen zu filmen
was lecker walter wir haben fünf stunden
gewartet dass meine nase wenn ich nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend an dieser
stelle wünschen heutigen blog jetzt
allerdings auch beenden weil damen und
herren ich bin leider immer noch ein
bisschen krank
ich glaube das kann man hören ich glaube
das kann man auch sehen daher will ich
nicht allzu fit und kann nicht so
richtigen content bremen von wegen ja
wir machen jetzt diese machen jetzt das
sogenannte am strand schildenfeld bläser
in study ems vor und ich meine die sind
teilweise echt verstörend gewesen teilt
so viel kann ich wirklich viel härter
balance bleibt wenn euch der blog heute
gefallen hat das gerne mal einen leicht
davon schreibt mir gerne und in die
kommentare was euer alter ist
ich bin 22 und dann sehen wir uns im
nächsten blog über magen
[Musik]